Film Courage: Dan we know you love sports.
Let’s say you had five minutes to sit down
with a filmmaker before they make their short
film, you are their coach.
What are you going to coach them on?
They haven’t made it yet.
Maybe they’re ready to go.
They have a script.
Daniel Sol, CoFounder of The Hollyshorts Film
Festival: I think the biggest thing is going
back to belief in the story you’re trying
to tell.
And I say that in the sense of anything you
do whether you play sports, the festival.
Say you’re a basketball coach and you don’t
love basketball.
How are you going to put the passion and energy
into succeeding.
You can’t.
You will loose.
You will fail.
It’s the same with a story or a film.
You want to get together with different people.
You have to rally up grips and DPs.
Their crew, PA’s, assistants to help you
and follow you in any way that you need.
Actors that are going to say that I’m going
to emotionally give to you and I’m not ready
to do this because you don’t seem that interested
or invested in this because you don’t believe
in the story or even know anything about the
story.
That’s why I go back to what I said earlier.
You have to tell the story you know.
Tell the story that you know that you can
make.
Don’t try to do something that is not familiar
to you just because “Daniel said this is
what you have to do to get in festivals.
You make it this way.”
Or some festival programmer said…yes but
your film has to be great (inherently good)
anyway.
It doesn’t matter genre or style or whatever.
It has to just be good.
And a good film comes from someone who believes
in their story and is passionate about their
story they make.
Any film that has won our festival or won
awards, they are not films that were made
with just blasé effort.
It’s just not happening.
These films were dedication, hours spent,
money lost, and a belief in the story.
Understanding the story they are trying to
tell because they have a grasp on it.
They are really passionate about what they
wrote.
Many times the filmmakers in the short space
are…a lot of times.
Not every time (of course not).
A lot of times it’s a writer/director that’s
the same person, right?
So if you wrote the script you should know
the material well.
If you didn’t write it then you believe
in it strongly.
You say “Hey I want to team up and make
this film and I can direct it.
You are writing, I can direct your story.”
But you have to have that passion and belief.
Because if you don’t have that you are just
going to fail.
The film won’t be good.
There will be areas will it will falter.
A lot of people will know that you are not
someone to follow because if you are directing
a group of people the same way you are managing
someone or coaching.
If you are talking to the players and they
know you are talking out of your behind and
you don’t believe what you are saying.
And you’re giving a half-hearted effort,
they know it, they sense it.
They are not going to fight for you, they
are not going to care.
Same way as with crew, actors, if you want
someone to give you their all as an actor
(especially with the actors), they are passionate,
they try to give themselves to you.
Whether it’s emotional stuff, whether it’s
a breakdown scene, or it’s a fight scene
or a couple arguing.
And they are having real issues, they are
a married couple.
Two actors, they are not married, they are
two actors.
You have to believe that they are a married
couple and they’re fighting.
You’ve got to get it out of them.
And how do you do that if they don’t like
you at all?
Or they don’t believe what you’re trying
to do?
Or how you’re trying to direct them and
the story you are trying to tell.
Or it’s how you operate.
Like if you don’t feel your belief and passion
for what the story is being made then they
are going to give a half-hearted effort and
it’s not going to be good.
Or they are going to want to get out of there
and knock the lines out and go home, like
you’re done with these people.
They don’t care.
This is not for me or this is not good enough
for me, whatever (and just get it over with).
I think that’s a big thing and it sounds
simple and obvious but it’s not always the
case.
A lot of people in life do a lot of things
half-hearted or don’t believe in what they
are doing…or think they do but don’t…or
in this case when it comes to storytelling
maybe they just want to try to impress and
just make a story that is not their own or
is something that they don’t believe in
because they don’t know the material well
enough or they don’t understand the nature
of what they are trying to tell with the story.
It will probably end up showing whether it’s
a writing flaw or going back to the analogy
of sports, what if it’s a basketball story
and it makes no sense in terms of the basketball
setting.
The writer doesn’t understand basketball,
doesn’t like basketball.
It’s going to show that they don’t know
what the heck they’re talking about.
The story won’t make sense.
As a viewer watching the movie you are watching
a scene of a basketball game and the score
makes no sense and it’s not really making
any sense as to what an actual sporting event
would be like then it wouldn’t make sense.
Then it’s like this is stupid, this is a
bad movie and you don’t even understand
the story that they are trying to tell, they
don’t even know the sport.
If you’re using analogies for baseball or
basketball, things like that.
Keeping it in the sports realm.
So yes, really knowing and loving what you
are trying to do with the project first and
foremost is critical.
It’s just a must.
And you will see it reflect.
I go back to the winners [for the Hollyshorts
Film Festival] because if you are winning
the festival (our festival or others) being
nominated for Oscars, those films aren’t
made with a lack of passion or effort or belief
in the story.
None of those filmmakers who have made those
stories have gone that far on just some casual
whim “Let’s just make this thing in one
day.
We’ll just knock it out and just cram and
who cares about details.”
It’s not that.
It’s made with passion, time, dedication
and effort.
All of those things.
Not to mention talent and all of those things.
You have to have that so that’s I think
the biggest thing.